DAN: SO THE SHOCKING ROUND TWO
OF THE TWITTER FILES SHOW MY
NEXT GUEST WAS ALSO SHADOW BAND
AND PUT ON A DO NOT AMPLIFY
LIST.
JOINING ME, CHARLIE KIRK.
CHARLIE, THIS IS THE KIND OF
THING YOU AND I HAVE BEEN
ACTIVISTS ABOUT FOR THE LAST FEW
YEARS.
YOU AND I AMONGST MANY OTHERS
I'M ASSUMING WERE VICTIMS OF
THIS.
>> WE ARE IN THIS TOGETHER ALONG
WITH SOME OF THE TOP PEOPLE
INDIVIDUALLY TRIGGERED BY
TWITTER.
YOUR PODCAST IS HUGE, YOU REACH
MILLIONS OF PEOPLE.
AND YOU ARE SUCCESSFUL IN THE
PARALLEL ECONOMY WITH RUMBLE.
I VENTURA GUESS THAT THEY
TARGETED ME BECAUSE OF "TURNING
POINT USA."
THE WORK WE ARE DOING ON HIGH
SCHOOL AND COLLEGE CAMPUSES.
THE MILLIONS OF YOUNG PEOPLE WE
ARE REACHING.
DO NOT AMPLIFY.
THAT'S THE SMOKING GUN, DAN.
DAN: THE DROP ON THURSDAY NIGHT
WAS HORRIFYING.
I'M SURE YOUR PHONE WAS BLOWING
UP.
BUT THE POST IMPORTANT PART OF
THIS IS IT MAY NOT JUST BE BIG
TECH.
BUT THE FBI WAS MEETING WITH
THEM BEFORE THE ELECTION.
WE ALREADY KNOW THAT.
THE LAST TIME I CHECKED, THE FBI
IS A BRANCH OF THE GOVERNMENT.
>> THAT'S RIGHT.
SO THIS SHOULD BE ILLEGAL.
THE NEXT QUESTION IS WHY DID
TWITTER DO THIS AND WHO TOLD
THEM TO DO THIS, AND WERE THEY
THREATENED TO DO THIS BY A
CERTAIN GOVERNMENT AGENCY?
DID THE CDC THREATEN THEM?
DID THE FDA THREATEN THEM?
DID ANTHONY FAUCI?
DID THE FBI?
I MET WITH DORSEY IN 2019.
IT WAS A WARM MEETING AND HE
DENIED HE WAS SHADOW-BANNING.
BUT SOMETHING CHANGED.
I THINK TWITTER WAS THREATENED
BY OUR GOVERNMENT TO COME AFTER
YOU AND COME AFTER ME AND